[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 la
participación de las mujeres en política
es fundamental para la supervivencia de
una verdadera democracia la gobernanza
incluyente promueve el cambio y el
desarrollo pero aún estamos lejos de la
paridad en américa latina' los últimos
15 años han marcado avances en la
materia pero el camino es largo uno de
los ejemplos de lucha es colombia por
eso en este programa vamos a conversar
con maría emma mejía una mujer que ha
sido parte de la historia nacional
periodista política y diplomática es
testigo de una lucha por hacer política
en tiempos violentos que golpearon
siempre con más fuerza a las que
nacieron mujeres con cargos que pasaron
desde la promoción del arte y la cultura
hasta los más altos estrados de la
representación diplomática internacional
maría emma hizo un alto para reflexionar
sobre los pasos dados y nos presentó su
libro de memorias el camino que abrimos
la paridad de legítima del ejercicio
democrático sin embargo pocos países
cumplen con las normas de igualdad en la
participación a diferencia de naciones
como españa finlandia ruanda a costa
rica o suecia donde la participación
femenina está incluso por encima del 50%
la paridad de la américa latina es una
lucha progresiva
ecuador bolivia y costa rica fueron
pioneros en 2008 con la incorporación de
la paridad en sus constituciones y en
adelante la aprobación de cuota de
género en argentina impulsó una ola de
avances regionales sostenidos aunque no
libres de obstáculos como la falta de
sanciones por incumplimiento o las
garantías de una posición igualitaria
para las mujeres en cargos públicos
entre 2019 y 2020 américa latina y el
caribe alcanzaron con 10 países el
número más alto de legislaciones
paritarias en el ámbito político
electoral una política exitosa en la
mayoría de casos para incrementar el
número de mujeres electas pese a que
colombia está entre los gobiernos que
han avanzado en la materia actualmente
las cifras de participación política son
preocupantes en el congreso las mujeres
representan apenas el 18 por ciento en
la cámara de representantes y el 21% en
el senado en las últimas elecciones
regionales se eligieron sólo el 6 por
ciento de mujeres gobernadoras en las
alcaldías ocupan apenas el 12% y son
minoría en los ministerios del gobierno
colombia es un país que nunca ha tenido
una mujer presidenta una pésima
referencia frente a un llamado cada vez
más urgente a atender la necesidad de
más mujeres gobernantes la secretaria de
la mujer del país recalcó que se ha
comprobado que cuando las mujeres se
encuentran en los espacios de decisión
política o cuando hay paridad se
promueven políticas públicas leyes y
cambios que impactan de manera favorable
en la sociedad pero en colombia los
liderazgos femeninos se ejercen bajo
amenazas y violencias por parte de
grupos al margen de la ley vamos a la
conversación que hoy es con maría emma
mejía periodista política y diplomática
colombiana amante del cine y del ballet
ex embajadora de colombia en la onu ex
ministra de exteriores y de educación y
consejera para la paz entre otros
mariah demás bienvenida a ella sois
muchas gracias gracias por esta
invitación a usted y vamos a comenzar
sin más su libro el camino que abrimos
es un ejercicio de memoria que nos
refresca mucho los episodios históricos
de un durísimo camino por la paz en
colombia' pero además es prueba de la
dificultad de hacer política incluyente
por muchos años usted fue un lunar en
las salas de reuniones llenas de hombres
eso ha cambiado
ha cambiado pero muy poco no en la
medida en que lo hemos debido hacer
nosotros hemos debido avanzar en una
política de género mucho antes sacar
leyes de equidad de género que
lamentablemente se demoraron mucho en el
congreso en este momento aún en colombia
ahora que vamos a tener elecciones
presidenciales y congresionales pues las
mujeres son la minoría menos del 19 por
ciento hoy en el congreso de colombia
que no es una cifra buena y eso lo
evidenciamos hace un momento en nuestro
reporte al leer su libro además es muy
evidente para mí la importancia de las
figuras de su abuelo y de su papá que la
prepararon de alguna manera para asumir
la vida pública que después llevó en una
casa llena de hermanas su papá tomó la
decisión de crearla usted como un
muchachito esa fue su manera de darle la
oportunidad o las oportunidades que
culturalmente no le tocaban porque usted
no nació hombre hoy en día con una
conciencia diferente de lo que es ser
mujer y entendiendo que ni la
masculinidad y la feminidad son
características de géneros sino de
humanos es nuestro deber marc y además
crear niña sin discriminación y para
liderar
por supuesto porque esa idea que existía
entonces que cuando yo nací usted tiene
razón el libro pero yo lo que aparece en
el libro es ella diciendo otra manera
está pues una niña y no obtener miedo
para él lo más importante es que las
mujeres a veces éramos como miedos a son
inseguras y creo que esa formación es
muy importante y muchas veces y no le
temamos tampoco a eso él los guías los
que nos forman es una zona en hombres y
creo que eso tampoco es que sea grave de
alguna forma tus maestros pueden ser eso
pero para las niñas y los niños está
particularmente las niñas y las jóvenes
está este libro y creo que ahí es como
donde yo creo que hay mayor importancia
y mayor contribución de una u otra forma
es a que ellas veían eso no tenerle
miedo de ser la única en una reunión y
ayudarnos entre mujeres que creo que es
un acto de solidaridad fundamental pues
mire a mí personalmente me queda muy
claro y muy en el fondo del corazón este
tema de no tenerle miedo a nada el miedo
no existe
además el problema de fondo no son las
figuras masculinas porque lo sano sería
que todos tuviéramos figuras paternas
figuras masculinas que aporten dentro de
nuestra formación el problema va
haciendo como asumimos esas
masculinidades y cómo esas masculinidad
es han sido históricamente pues están
discriminatorias y a propósito de eso la
violencia política contra las mujeres
esto es una constante en américa latina
es una constante en colombia' los
liderazgos femeninos sobreviven a duras
penas bajo condiciones de amenazas de
violencias de grupos al margen de la ley
y más aún en las regiones rurales usted
esto se lo sabe de memoria en un país
como colombia que pasa al interior del
aparato político que aún está muy lejos
de ser la prioridad proteger a nuestras
mujeres lideresas
es aterrador
colombia está progresando un momento muy
complejo donde los líderes sociales las
liderezas sociales han sido igualmente
amenazadas y hemos perdido figuras muy
significativas en la colombia rural en
la colombia urbana en un país tan escaso
de liderazgos donde la mujer empieza a
notarse particularmente en las juntas de
acción comunal en los barrios de
medellín es un ejemplo yo acabo de
llegar de medellín de la comuna
nororiental donde antes dominaba el
narcotráfico pablo escobar era el rey
yerno de ese ejército de niñas y niños
sicarios y sicarios el 11 ve que la
mujer tiene un enorme potencial
directivo y que de alguna forma no la
hemos protegido y las leyes de género
han sido muy escasas en un país como
colombia que signatario de los
principales convenios internacionales
que puede ser inclusive buscado por ello
hablamos de los tratados internacionales
la participación de las mujeres los
objetivos del desarrollo sostenible no
solamente debe darse con paridad sino
que debe darse con condiciones de
igualdad pero esa no es una realidad aún
en el poder las mujeres sufren
intimidación sufren acoso sufren
discriminación como ha sido para usted
siendo una mujer tan preparada y con
tantas décadas de experiencia política
enfrentarse a eso
la receta creo yo y el éxito que hemos
tenido nosotros hemos sido siete
cancilleres mujeres en colombia en ahora
estamos conmemorando los 200 años de
creación de la cancillería colombiana de
lo lo que entonces se conocía como
secretaria de estado en relaciones
internacionales es precisamente como
descubrir esos espacios que tenemos no
se le pide que colombia fue una mujer
colombiana de la cancillería la que
abrió dijéramos el elemento de
sostenibilidad
introdujo el elemento de sostenibilidad
los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible es no
y fue colombia sin nadar ya en el año de
los 80 de la comisión de paridad de
género de igualdad de género
la importancia es mostrar la visibilizar
a la mujer eran muy poquitas las que
firmaron la carta las que redactaron la
carta sólo cinco mujeres de 200
delegados eran mujeres dos
latinoamericanas hace 76 años
rescatamos en un libro que sea más
perentoria es la historia de las mujeres
naciones unidas y siempre aunque pocas
dejaron mucha huella en el preámbulo de
la carta por primera vez aparece la
palabra si en algún documento tratado
internacional el ella y en el artículo
octavo también de la carta de naciones
así que es muy muy bonito ver como en a
lo largo de la historia y de la historia
de colombia también de nuestra nación
pues la mujer ha estado muy presente
bueno mar y además y porque si nos
tienen que importar las cuotas de género
por qué es tan difícil cumplirlas los
partidos políticos se quejan de que ya
de hecho es difícil tener un 30 por
ciento de mujeres no digamos el 50
es aterrador lo que usted dice es
absolutamente cierto ayer en un panel
precisamente sobre feminismo con ingrid
betancourt y wang y dagoberto es una
representante de la cámara lo hablábamos
y cuando ella presentó una ley de
paridad de género para que en estas
listas al congreso que se va a elegir en
5 meses hubiera un hombre una mujer un
hombre una mujer o una mujer un hombre
en listas cerradas
pues yo no no es que el hombre el
congresista le digo no pues es que eso
quiere decir que vamos a tener la mitad
de los congresistas no solo la mitad de
ellos pero obvio que vamos a tener la
mitad porque es que el mundo está hecho
de la mitad acá somos nosotras entonces
en el siglo 21 entonces el grupo que
dice bueno esto no puede estar pasando
pues mire le agradezco mucho por su
tiempo el libro hay que leerlo y esa es
la única manera de hacer la revisión
histórica como debe ser y de una
pregunta abierta que no me alcanza
responder pero nos queda para pensarla y
es una mujer presidente en colombia para
cuando muchas gracias a ustedes y a
nuestros televidentes que sigan en
france24 y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas
[Música]